Salut, ce matin à la demande générale
de ce que vous avez sur Facebook, Twitter et dans les commentaires Youtube
Je vous fais un Master Class' sur les verbes irréguliers en anglais.
Ça sent la rigolade !
Y'a pas de technique magique, mais y'a plein de techniques pratiques.
Y'a 200 verbes - à peu près - irréguliers en anglais, c'est beaucoup 200 verbes.
Pour tout vous dire même les anglais eux mêmes ne connaissent pas tous leurs verbes irréguliers.
Et un verbe irrégulier c'est un infinitif, un prétérit et un participe passé.
Petit bonus quand même, il y a plein de verbes qui ont la même forme de base,
le même prétérit et le même participe passé.
Identifiez-les, et commencez par apprendre ceux-là.
Comme "Permettre" qui se dit - to let - let - let
Bon bin let - let - let
Il ne faut pas se priver de ça !
Il faut surtout apprendre les plus simples en premier
Il n'y a pas d'ordre prédéfini, il n'y a que votre ordre à vous, qui compte.
Ensuite vous pouvez continuer à apprendre par groupe
en constituant vous-même les groupes qui vous intéressent.
Vous pouvez construire un groupe de verbes
dont le participe passé et la forme de base sont identiques
et comme ça, vous avez juste à apprendre le verbe, sa traduction et son prétérit.
Ça vous fait une étape en moins.
Personnellement, moi j'avais construit des groupes de verbes qui subissaient la même transformation.
C'est à dire qu'au prétérit, ils finissaient tous par la lettre "t"
Vous pouvez, dans cette piscine de verbes irréguliers, trouver votre propre logique
pour faire vos propres groupes.
Et là on rejoint ce que je dis à chaque fois sur les vidéos  sur la mémoire,
c'est vos techniques à vous, vos préférences, qui vont faire que vous allez mieux retenir.
Quand je dis apprendre par groupe, d'ailleurs, ce n'est pas anodin
il vaut mieux apprendre par groupe de 10
voire de 20
et par petit groupe de 10, et régulièrement injecter un nouveau groupe de 10
plutôt que d'essayer de faire une grosse masse d'un coup.
Quand vos groupes sont faits, quand ils sont écrits, quand ils sont identifiés,
commencez par le groupe que vous aimez le plus
qui vous semble le plus simple à retenir.
Ne vous compliquez pas la vie.
Mais pour bien ancrer tout ça dans votre mémoire
et le tenir dans le long terme
il va falloir trouver d'autres techniques.
Mais bon, c'est pour ça que je fais un Master'class.
Une technique qui fonctionne très bien
c'est la visualisation. Comme d'habitude
le cerveau adore se nourrir des images.
Quand vous apprenez un verbe, visualisez l'action qu'il représente.
Ayez une image précise de l'action, de ce que ça veut dire réellement.
Et si vous voulez être vraiment malin, vous allez utiliser les principes de la mnémotechnique
que je vous ai expliqué la semaine dernière dans une vidéo.
Grâce à ça vous allez tout associer ensemble.
L'image de l'action, le fait de l'avoir verbalisé dans une phrase
et un ancrage mental pour faciliter la récupération.
Exemple pour "voir" : See - Saw - Seen
Je vais simplement visualiser plein de gens autour d'une table,
en train de regarder six saucisses,
dans une grosse assiette.
Six saucisses.
Quand je vais penser à "voir" je vais penser à toutes ces personnes en train de regarder le plat où il y a six saucisses,
et instantanément je vais me rappeler de See - Saw - Seen
"Seen", "Six", on s'est compris.
Une fois que vous avez fait tous vos petits groupes
que vous les avez isolés
que vous avez peut-être trouvé des moyens techniques pour les apprendre
vous les imprimez, vous les découpez, vous les notez sur des post-it
où vous voulez, mais vous en mettez partout :
dans votre portefeuille, dans vos toilettes...
On le sait aujourd'hui, ce n'est plus un secret, l'endroit où l'on apprend le mieux ses verbes irréguliers c'est aux toilettes,
dans votre voiture, dans votre sac ...
L'idée c'est d'optimiser toutes les minutes perdues de votre vie
pour pouvoir réviser en permanence les verbes irréguliers
et les groupes que vous avez défini.
C'est l'idéal, parce que vous n'allez pas consacrer de temps à ça.
Vous allez juste récupérer du temps perdu à droite à gauche.
Si vous êtes conducteur dans les bouchons
vous ne vous ennuierez plus, vous réviserez vos verbes irréguliers.
Aux toilettes, vous apprenez votre anglais.
Durant les publicités à la télé, vous pouvez vous les repasser dans votre tête
et si vous avez un trou, vous regardez.
Quand quelqu'un vous parle, et que vous faites semblant d'écouter
(Ne me la faites pas je sais que vous le faites des fois)
Repassez-vous vos groupes dans la tête.
En faisant ça, je peux vous assurer qu'en quelques semaines vous connaîtrez les 50 principaux verbes irréguliers.
Et encore je vous dis en quelques semaines, mais ça va être plus rapide que ça
avec la traduction, la forme de base, le prétérit, le participe passé.
Comme on est samedi, et que le samedi c'est le master'class,
je vous ai donné plein de possibilités, plein de techniques différentes
et j'espère que vous allez piocher un petit peu là dedans
pour optimiser votre apprentissage des verbes irréguliers.
Et bien sûr, si ce genre de master'class vous plait
mettez un pouce en l'air pour me le faire savoir.
vous pouvez aussi vous abonner à la chaîne ou me laisser un commentaire.
Je lis tous vos commentaires, ne l'oubliez pas,
et en plus, en général j'y réponds.
Tout à l'heure, à 16h, ce sera le live que je fais sur périscope
le premier live, c'était pour fêter les 2500 abonnés
on est déjà 11 000 c'est super !
Prenez votre menthe à l'eau avec vous
je le fais sur périscope parce que je ne maîtrise pas encore bien les live sur youtube
et que je ne voulais pas reporter la date.
Je ne sais pas si je pourrai garder la vidéo pour la partager sur youtube après.
Je découvre tout ça en même temps que vous.
Passez un excellent samedi, quoi qu'il arrive rendez-vous demain à 11h pour le prochain mental vlog, ciao !